Сучасна роботизована техніка тут використовується
не для виготовлення пристроїв, а для їхнього розбирання.
318 мільйонів євро заплатить адміністрація Гонконгу
берлінській компанії Alba протягом десяти років
за те, що та перероблятиме електронне сміття міста.
Значна частина електронних відходів Гонконгу
вивозиться в країни третього світу, де переробляється в поганих умовах.
Це було основною проблемою. Ми не маємо експортувати сміття з Гонконгу.
45 мільйонів тонн електромотлоху щороку викидає людство.
Це як вага 4,5 тисяч Ейфелевих веж.
І лише 20% приладів утилізуються відповідно до екологічних норм.
Приміром, однин житель Гонконгу викидає 20 кілограмів електроприладів на рік.
Левова частка цього електромотлоху зникає
на сірих міжнародних ринках електровідходів.
Тепер цьому хочуть покласти край.
Мешканці Гонконгу можуть безкоштовно  віддати своє сміття
німецькій компанії Alba на переробку.
Платити за це мусять виробники.
Маріо Шульце керував плануванням та будівництвом заводу,
на якому нині працюють 140 працівників.
Вони мають забезпечити не лише правильну утилізацію електросміття,
але й налагодити електронну систему, завдяки якій
можна буде будть-якої миті відстежити, які прилади
поступили на переробку і що з ними сталося.
- Як тільки виявляються пристрої, які походять
не з Гонконгу, а були імпортовані, ми негайно їх
відсортовуємо та повідомляємо про це Агенцію із захисту навколишнього середовища.
Завод вважається одним з найсучасніших
у Південно-Східній Азії і незабаром буде утилізувати
дві третини електронного мотлоху Гонконгу.
Проте для фірми це лише початок.
- Німецькі технології мають багато перспектив в Азії.
Електронні відходи дедалі більше розглядаються
як глобальна проблема. Китай оголосив про те, що
хоче збудувати серію нових заводів з переробки електронних відходів.
Японія і Корея також розширюють свої потужності.
І так у цілому регіоні, аж до Сінгапуру.
Рештки електронних відходів після переробки
здебільшого знову потрапляють на фабрики регіону,
де з них виробляється нове покоління електронних приладів.